these Milestones puts into perspective
what this climate conference is all
about
how will we answer when baby 8 billion
is old enough to ask
what did you do for our worlds and for
our planet when you have the chance
excellencies these U.N climate
conference is a reminder that the answer
is in our ends
and the clock is ticking
we are in the fight of our lives and we
are losing
greenhouse gas emissions keep growing
global temperatures keep Rising
and our planet is fast approaching
tipping points that will make climate
chaos irreversible
we are on a highway to climate hell with
our foot still on the accelerator
the war in Ukraine
other conflicts have caused so much
bloodsheds and violence and their
dramatic impacts all over the world
but
we cannot
we cannot accept
that our attention is not focused on
climate change
we must of course work together to
support peace efforts and then the
tremendous suffering
but climate change is on a different
timeline and a different scale it is a
defining issue of our age it is the
central challenge of our century
it is unacceptable outrageous and
self-defeating to put it on the back
burner
indeed many of today's conflicts are
linked with growing climate chaos
and war in Ukraine has exposed the
profound risks of our forcing full
addiction
and today's crisis cannot be an excuse
for backsliding or greenwashing
even is seeing there a reason for
greater urgency stronger action and
effective accountability
excellencies human activity is the cause
of the climate problem so Human Action
must be the solution
action to re-establish ambition and
action to rebuild trust especially
between North and South
the science is clear any help of
limiting temperature rise to 1.5 degrees
means achieving global net zero
emissions by 2050.
but at 1.5 degree goal is on life
support
and the machines are rattling
we are getting dangerously close to the
point of no return
and to avoid that dire fate all G20
countries must accelerate their
transition now in these decades
developed countries must take the leads
but emerging economies are also critical
to bending the global emissions curve
last year in Glasgow I called for
coalitions of support for high emitting
emerging economies to accelerate the
transition from coal towards Renewables
we are making progress with the Just
Energy transition Partnerships but much
more is needed
and that is why at the beginning of cop
27
I'm calling for a historic pact between
developed and developing economies and
specially developed and emerging
economies a climate solidarity Pact
a pact in which all countries make an
extra effort to reduce emissions these
decades in line with 1.5 degree goal
a pact in which wealthier countries and
international financial institutions
provide financial and technical
assistance to help emerging economies
speed their own renewable energy
transition
effect to Independence on fossil fuels
and the building of new coal plants
phasing out coal in oecd countries by
2030 and everywhere else by 2040.
a peck that will provide Universal
affordable sustainable energy for all
a pet in which developed and the
emerging economies United on the common
strategy and combined capacities and
resources for the benefit of humankind
the two largest economies the United
States and China have a particular
responsibility to join efforts to make
this pact a reality
and this is our only hope of meeting our
climate goals
Humanity has a choice cooperate or
perish it is either a climate solidarity
pact or a collective suicide pact
excellence
is
foreign
at the same time we must acknowledge a
harsh truth there is no adapting to a
growing number of catastrophic events
causing enormous suffering around the
world
the deadly impacts of climate change are
here and now
loss and damage can no longer be swept
under the rug
it is a moral imperative it is a
fundamental question of international
solidarity and climate Justice
those who contributed lists to The
Climate crisis are reaping the Whirlwind
sown by others
and many are blindsided by impacts for
which they had no warning or means of
preparation
this is why I'm calling for a universal
early warning system coverage within
five years
and it is why I am asking that all
governments tax the wind for profits the
fossil full companies
let's redirect that money to people
struggling with Rising food and energy
prices and to countries suffering loss
and damage caused by the climate crisis
on addressing loss and damage this cop
must agree on a clear time-bound roadmap
reflective of the scale and urgency of
the challenge
and this roadmap must deliver effective
institutional arrangements for financing
getting concrete results on loss and
damage is a litmus test of the
commitment of the governments to the
success of cop 27.
excellencies and Friends
the good news is that we know what to do
and we have the financial and
technological tools to get the job done
it is time for Nations to come together
for implementation it is time for
international solidarity across the
boards
solidarity that respects all human
rights and guarantees a safe space for
environmental Defenders and all actors
in society to contribute to our climate
response
let's not forget that the war on nature
is itself a massive violation of Human
Rights
we need all hands on deck for faster
Bolder climate action
a window of opportunity remains open but
only a narrow shaft of light remains
the global climate fight will be won or
lost in these crucial decades on our
watch
and one thing is certain
those that give up are sure to lose
so let's fight together and let's win
for the 8 billion members of our human
family and four generations to come
thank you